[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX GOLD: Thanks so
much for tuning in today
to talk about managing packages
for open-source data science.
My name is Alex, and I'm a
solutions engineering manager
here at RStudio.
Just a little about me
so that you know who I am
and why I'm talking
about this, I'm
a former data scientist and
a data-science team lead.
I worked on health
care, politics,
economic policy kinds of issues
when I was a full-time data
scientist.
And since coming
to RStudio, I've
been a solutions engineer
here for about two years.
So that's me.
So let's dive right in and
talk about managing packages.
So data science is a lot
like this delicious sandwich.
This sandwich looks
incredible, by the way.
If you know how to
make this sandwich,
let me know, because wow.
Anyway, data science is a
little like making a delicious
sandwich.
Maybe it's an app
that you're making.
Maybe it's an API or a port or
a scheduled job of some sort.
And it takes a little bit of
planning, a little preparation,
and a little skill to make
something really, really great.
Today, we're going to talk
about one important aspect
of the open-source data science,
which is package management.
And so we'll start talking
about how package management can
screw up your plans to
make beautiful, delicious
sandwiches, or data-science
products, some background
on how it all works,
and then, finally, some
thoughts on how it can be
better and how it doesn't
have to always be so painful.
So let's dive right in.
So first, the pain.
So one reason this
can be painful
is that folks are
blocked, right?
You're blocked from
installing packages.
Either you don't
have permissions
to install on your
machine, or you're
blocked from public
package sources like CRAN,
Bioconductor, or PyPI--
and that's a big problem--
or you have no way to
share private packages.
And I will say that there
are some organizations that
have bans against installing
stuff to your own machine.
And there's sort of
no way around that.
But hopefully what you can come
out of this presentation with
is some information on how
to work with your IT team
to get to a situation to
do the work that you really
need to do.
And that leads into the
situation of it feeling like IT
and data science are at odds.
And this isn't so
surprising, right?
Data scientists want
the software they want,
and they want it
when they want it.
And that's not necessarily
always IT's concern, right?
IT or admins have a lot
of concern about platform
stability and security.
And those things don't have to
be at odds, but they can be.
And so that can be a problem.
There's the issue of fragility.
When you're sharing your
project with somebody else,
are you confident
that they'll be
able to open it up
and actually use it?
Or might they open
it up and find
themselves stuck because they
don't have the right package
set?
And then, lastly,
when you come back
to a project in the
future, this is just a form
of sharing with future you.
But how confident are you
that your package set hasn't
changed in the meantime and you
can get back to the same state?
And so to be
completely clear, you
can't fix all these problems.
And particularly, if you're
just a lone data scientist,
it may not be possible
to fix all these.
You may need some help from
others at your organization.
But you can set yourself
up for success here.
And so let's talk a
little bit about how.
I love to cook.
And when you're
talking about cooking,
there's this
concept called "mise
en place," which means
"putting in place" in French.
That's just my understanding.
I don't speak French.
But what it's really about
is, you cup, measure, and prep
all of your ingredients before
you ever turn on your stove,
right?
So by the time you're
turning on the gas,
by the time you're
starting to cook,
everything is in place and
ready to go by that time.
And so one of the reasons that--
you can't guarantee
outcomes, but you can really
guarantee your process.
And so that's what the
mise-en-place step is meant
to do when you're cooking.
And you can do something
very similar, right?
Package management is very
much like the mise en place
of doing data science, right?
It's getting all
your ingredients,
all your things in
place before you go.
So let's take a step back
and talk a little bit about,
how do the ingredients get
there in the first place?
And how do you make
sure they're ready to go
when you're doing data science?
We're going to stick
with this metaphor.
So your food starts at
the grocery store, right?
It's packaged up.
It's on the shelf.
It's ready to go.
And you go and get it.
And then when you want
to cook something,
you go and buy the
right ingredients,
and you bring them home
to your pantry, right?
There's this shopping process.
You go and you fill
your shopping cart.
You pay for it.
You take it home.
And it's very
similar for packages.
So that's the
shopping thing where
the stuff gets from the
grocery store to your pantry.
And it's really the
same for packages.
For packages, your grocery
store is your repository.
And so this is an
external place where
you have all of your
packages, and they're
stored, ready for you
to go in an inert way.
And then there's your library.
And that is your
pantry where you
keep your packages that are
just for you and the things
you're going to make.
And that's how that works.
And so for many teams, the
repository that they use
is public, right?
It might be public CRAN, public
Bioconductor, public package
manager.
Other teams choose to maintain
private repositories--
RStudio Package Manager and
miniCRAN, something else.
That's really fine.
But the libraries
are always private.
And the libraries are
anywhere there's a kitchen,
anywhere there's actual R
or Python processes running
in the IDE, in a notebook,
on RStudio Connect,
in a Docker container, right?
There's a library
attached to that.
And the shopping process
is the install, right?
So the packages get from
the grocery-store repository
into your private pantry
library via the install.
And just to be a little
more precise about this,
I have these two
sorted side by side,
but really the way this works
is that like the grocery store,
and pantries, many libraries
are served by one repository,
right?
One repository provides
packages for many libraries.
And so let's dive in a
little bit on how that works.
So a repository is
just a file server.
It has a bunch of directories
indexed in a particular way.
And so just to be precise
[INAUDIBLE] this is the link.
You'll note it's a URL, right?
It's a real link to an internet
site for a particular package
on CRAN, right?
Now, CRAN is the main R package
repository-- public one.
And so what you'll see here
is, this is for Windows.
It is using the
development version of R--
R version 4.1.
It is for the A3
package, which I
chose because it is the
alphabetically first package
on CRAN.
And it's version 1.0.0.
And so literally, this is
the directory structure
inside the CRAN repository.
And so this is just
a directory that's
organized in this
particular way that
R-- when you go to
install a package,
it knows how to walk
this tree and get
the package in the package
versions that you need.
One of the other important
aspects of the repository
is that the repository
is not local.
It is almost never the
case that your repository
is on the same machine
as where you're actually
doing your work.
Very often, the
repository is going
to be actually in the cloud.
It's actually going to be a
website, like that URL I just
showed you.
Or, sometimes, it's going to be
an internal networked server.
But usually, even
if you're doing
work on, like, RStudio
Server, it's almost never
going to be on the same server.
It's going to be a
different server.
That's very much in
contrast to the library.
The library is just a directory.
But it's on the same machine
as the running R process.
And so you'll see,
this is a Linux path
to inside my home directory.
It's the R x86,
64 Linux library.
And you'll see, this is
specific to R version
4.1 and the A3 package.
And so one of the
big differences
here is that libraries are
specific to the version of R.
They are not specific
to the package version.
And this is because R needs a
way to resolve, definitively,
to a particular package.
And in particular,
the thing that
arises here is, some
people wonder, oh,
why couldn't you just have
a package version here?
And the reason is that, then,
when A3 has dependencies
that it needs to go get,
it needs to be able to,
at some level, fetch
those by name, right?
It needs to just get
the version that's there
and not maintain many
versions at once.
And so this is one of
the big distinctions
between the repository
and the library,
is that the library
has, at most,
one version of any package.
The repository has many
versions of each package,
and even many versions for
different operating systems.
And in either case, the thing
that ties it all together
is your settings on
your machine, right?
That tells your R or Python
process what repository to use,
what library to use--
that sort of thing.
And so one thing I want
to make really clear
is that this is the
same for R and Python.
There are some minor
differences in tooling, which
we'll get to in just a moment.
But everything I've talked about
so far, and most everything I'm
going to talk about for
the rest of this webinar,
is identical in R and Python.
The conceptual way that
repositories and libraries
house packages is exactly
the same in R and Python.
So let's get a little
into the nitty-gritty
here of how these
package installs actually
work in R and Python.
So let's say I go to
install a package.
In R, I do that with
install.packages.
In Python, I do that
with pip install package.
And you'll notice, here is
one of the differences, which
is that, in R, I do all of
my actual package management
and installation
from inside R, right?
I type install.packages at
a running R interpreter.
That's different in Python.
In Python, you use
a separate binary
to manage your package installs.
Most often, that's pip.
It can also be
something like conda.
But either way, it's a separate
thing from your running Python
process.
You don't do this in
a Python interpreter.
You do this at the command line.
And so that's a
difference in tooling.
But in terms of
what these tools do,
they are conceptually identical.
So in either case, what
they're going to do
is they're going to
look at your settings.
In particular, in R, it's going
to look at your options repos.
In Python, it's going to
look at your pip config.
And from there, it's going to
find the URL of a repository.
And remember, this is
going to be a real URL,
either on the internet
or a networked server.
And from there, it's
going to move that package
into your particular library.
Now, when I go to
actually load a package,
in either R or
Python, I do that in R
with the library
package command.
In Python, I do it
with import package.
And so what I'm going to
do from there is I'm going
to-- or, what R or Python are
going to do [INAUDIBLE] going
to look at the-- in R, the
.libPaths, or in Python,
the sys.path.
Hopefully, you've never had
to look at these before,
because they just
resolve automatically.
From that, R and Python will
know which library to look to.
And we'll bring that back
into your running R or Python
environment.
And then you can use the
functions from those packages.
So this was a lot of
nitty-gritty, in-depth stuff.
And if this all
felt like this was
really exciting and intriguing
to you, congratulations.
You're a huge nerd, and
you're in great company.
So delighted to have you here.
But if this went over
your head a little bit
or didn't feel that
important, that's great.
That's totally fine.
You should never need
to manage this directly.
But I share all this
mainly to make the point
that you can see why this is
a little bit frustrating why
there's no single silver
bullet to make this all work.
Successfully managing
your package environment
requires at least three
different components, right?
It requires the repository, the
library, and the settings that
tie it all together, right?
All three of those
things need to work.
And so there's no
single silver bullet
to make this all just work.
That said, there
is a happy path.
It is possible to make this
delicious sandwich, whatever
it is.
And it's not even that hard.
But you're going to want to
do some planning up front.
You're going to want to
do your mise en place.
And so we're going
to talk, for the rest
of this talk, about two ways
that you can make this better.
And the first is to develop
a package-management plan
with your IT department.
And the second is [INAUDIBLE]
project-specific libraries
that you can manage as an
individual data scientist.
And so from here,
we're going to get
to the package-management
prime directive, which
is a little grandiose.
But I like this
slide so [INAUDIBLE]..
And so the first is
that repositories should
be as broad as possible, right?
These should be
managed centrally,
if they're being managed at all.
And they should try and serve
as many users as possible.
That is the opposite from
libraries, which are specific.
One other thing I should
mention about libraries
is that they are
pull only, right?
You have to pull packages
to your libraries.
And so that means that
the data scientist
should have control of what they
pull into their own libraries.
This is sometimes a point
of friction between IT teams
and data scientists.
And it's worth
having a conversation
with your IT team about how
you can safely manage libraries
as the data-science
team, because we've
see many, many people doing
it quite successfully.
So to dive in a
little bit on that,
who manages each
of these things?
So on your repository,
you don't necessarily
need to manage a repository.
A lot of organizations choose
not to manage a repository.
And we'll get, in a minute,
into why you might want to.
But many organizations choose
not to manage a repository.
If you are going to
manage one, that's
generally on IT or admins.
And sometimes you
have data scientists
serving in this role of the
data-science platform admin.
And that's fine.
But it's good to
distinguish what you're
doing as a data-science
platform admin
versus as a data scientist.
And so, most often,
we see IT admins
managing a repository,
because the job here
is to stand up a server, to
network it correctly, to make
sure that it's
available to users,
to make sure that it stays
up, has the appropriate amount
of stability and security.
And so these are
really IT admin tasks
in terms of managing
a repository.
On the library side, that really
falls to the data scientist--
to manage either a user-level
library or, increasingly,
and as I'm going to
suggest to do here,
a project-level library, right?
An individual library that
corresponds to a single project
is the safest path,
because then, you
know that, even if
you do other projects,
you won't have to worry about
breaking your project library.
And then the settings that
tie them together, right?
If you're on a server,
like RStudio Server,
this most often is administered
by the IT or the admin.
If you're on the
desktop, this is usually
administered by the
individual data scientist.
And so then the question
is, how do you manage this?
What are the tools that you use?
So on the repository
level, obviously, we
recommend using RStudio
Package Manager as the package
repository for CRAN,
Bioconductor, and PyPI
repositories.
There are also open-source
products like miniCRAN
that you can use, if that's
what your organization or you
prefer.
On the library side,
there's renv and virtualenv.
And this is another difference
between R and Python.
In R land, the two options
that most people use to do this
are either Packrat or renv.
Renv is a full
replacement for Packrat
and, in fact, was written
by the same person.
So if you're using
Packrat, upgrade to renv.
If you're not managing
project [INAUDIBLE] libraries,
start doing it.
Use renv.
On the Python side,
there are a ton
of options for how to do this.
There's virtualenv.
There's conda.
There's pyenv.
There's all these
different things.
And if your organization
has a standard, that's fine.
Use what you want to use.
But if you aren't
using anything yet,
I would encourage you
to use virtualenv.
It's relatively simple.
And as far as I've seen, I've
seen lots of organizations
successfully use virtualenv.
And so that's the one that
I recommend most often.
And in terms of
the settings, that
can be configured
inside the RStudio IDE,
if you're using the RStudio IDE.
Or you can use config files
like Rprofile or Rprofile.site
or Renviron or Renviron.site
to set those settings.
Great.
So let's talk a little bit
about why organizations want
to manage private repositories.
And the main reason
here is that when
IT needs to control
the set of packages
that's available to people,
this is how you do it.
And I want to emphasize
this, that if you are
in an organization where
you cannot install things--
install R packages
on your machine--
you're in a broken
state, and you
need to figure out a
way to convince your IT
team to let you install stuff.
It's really, really hard to
work in that environment.
One answer is to get
a centralized server.
But the other answer is to
allow installs only from a Py
private repository, right?
So that's [INAUDIBLE]
see people standing up
private repositories.
And that is because they're
in offline or air-gapped
situations.
That is, there's no access
to the internet from where
you're installing packages.
Now, that's a
common sort of thing
in high-security environments.
And that's totally fine.
The solution is to
have a repository
behind your firewall,
and then allow people
free and open access
to that repository
and lock them from
using any repository
outside the firewall.
Similarly, if you have
to validate package sets
into your environment, if
that's why you can't install
packages-- because you
can't install anything--
again, the way to
solve this problem
is to have the repository
be the gateway, right?
The repository chooses what
are the sets of packages
people are allowed to install
for safety or security reasons.
And then what they
can install-- this
can also work really well
if you have projects that
require package validation.
And then once those packages
have been validated,
you can only use that set.
This is a great way to
administer that, right?
You administer-- the IT
or admin administers it
at the repository level.
And then data scientists
are free to install
whatever packages are available
to them from the repository.
But they can't
get anything else.
All they can get is
what's in the repository.
And then the last piece
here is, if you're
doing private internal packages
that you're developing locally,
having an offline repository
can be a great way to do it.
So for the rest of
this presentation,
we're going to talk
about how to do
your mise en place with renv.
And we're going to talk
about some of the ways
that renv can be helpful here.
And that is by
isolating your libraries
on a per-project
basis, which we've
been talking about
being a good thing,
using a snapshotted repository
from RStudio Package Manager
to ensure
reproducibility later on,
sharing or restoring
a project when you're
sharing with a colleague or when
you're coming back to a project
after some time, and how
to start a new project
and easily do your mise
en place to make sure
that this works in a way
that you're happy with, too.
So first, let's open up
this very ominously named
package_fails project here.
And so what I want
to point out is,
this is some code in
an R Markdown document.
It last ran in 2018, in June.
I'm not going to get into
really what this code does.
And so what I'll say
upfront, actually,
is, what this code
does is pretty silly.
So please don't judge
me based on that.
What I wanted to do is I
wanted to find an example where
upgrading the package versions
would cause something to fail,
and in a tidyverse package,
because since we make
the tidyverse packages
here at RStudio,
I figured we could blame
ourselves, at least.
One thing I will
say is, actually, it
was hard to find an
example of this working.
If you saw Hadley's
talk at rstudio::global,
the tidyverse team is making
a huge effort to not break
people's code.
And it was actually quite
difficult to find an example
where this fails.
But anyway, so here is
code that ran in 2018.
And so I'm going to try
and run it today in 2021.
And what we're going to
find is that this code--
let me make this a little
bigger so it's easier to see--
this code no longer runs because
the argument data is missing.
It looks like it's there,
so I don't know what's up.
I mean, I do know what's up.
But we know this is the king of
thing that could take forever
to debug and get stuck here.
The eagle-eyed among
you will notice
that the problem is actually
that this argument was renamed
to dot data in tidyr later.
And so if I look here, what
version of tidyr am I running?
I am running tidyr 1.0.2.
Hmm.
So I happen to know
that, as of June--
and let's look again
at when this last ran.
This ran in June 2018.
And as of June 2018,
the version of tidyr
back then was, like, 0.8.1.
And so what's happened is,
tidyr has gotten upgraded,
because I did something
else on my system
that bumped the
version of tidyr.
And so now my code is broken.
It's just broken.
And that's really
frustrating, right?
There are ways to
fix this, but I've
got to spend time fixing it.
It would be ideal
if this had not
happened in the first place.
So let's go to the "much
more friendly named"
renv_working example here.
And what you'll see is, this
is exactly the same code.
Identical code.
And this is going to run.
Rmarkdown render.
Boom.
Done.
And now I've got a version
that works today, right?
This ran today, just now--
2/17/2021.
And so what's the
difference, right?
If you've been
paying attention, I'm
sure you've realized
the difference is
that I'm using renv here.
But let's, real
quick, just check.
So inside the working
version, the version of tidyr
is 0.8.1, whereas, in
the nonworking version,
it had gotten upgraded in
a way that I didn't really
mean for it to.
So that's great.
And to be transparent, let's
check out those .libPaths,
which I mentioned was the
way that it looks up where
the library is.
And so you'll see the
library, in this version--
this is my user-level library.
And this is the
system-level library.
So at some point, in my
user libraries since 2018,
I've updated the
version of tidyr, which
is not very hard to imagine.
On the other hand, inside
this version that works,
the libPaths point to--
this is my home directory.
So this is inside
the renv_working.
Inside this project,
there's an renv library
that is going to be keeping this
package safe for me for later.
So that's great.
Renv has done its job.
I am keeping myself safe.
So that solves one
problem, right?
My package versions will
stay consistent as long
as I keep this renv
project with this project.
So what happens, now, if I want
to install another package?
Let's say I want
to install ggplot.
Now, I did install
package ggplot.
Oh, great.
So it installed ggplot 2.2.1.
So that's great because ggplot
2.2.1, I happen to know,
is the version from June 2018.
Currently, ggplot2 is
on 3.3.3, which is not
the version I want, right?
That's too new.
It might break.
So how did I get ggplot2?
And of course, if I look
at my options repos, that's
the answer, is that my repo here
is pointed at a public RStudio
package manager.
And I happen to know that
this is the URL format.
That means that this
is a dated repo.
And so let's look
at what that means.
So here is RStudio
Package Manager.
This is public RStudio
Package Manager--
packagemanager.rstudio.com.
You can go there and
use it as you wish.
It's free and available to use.
And so what I'll see is that,
if I go here to the Setup pane,
I can get--
if I go back to June 2018,
there's that 72, right?
That is from that date.
So what that means-- that
every time I install packages
from this repository, they will
work together as of June 2018.
And so I never have to
worry about installing
a new version that's
going to mess things
up, because they will
always play nicely together.
The other thing I will
say-- and this is, again,
a thing that's different
between R and Python--
is that, in R, you
need to specify
that you want binary
repositories for your operating
system [INAUDIBLE] to
the operating system,
and you can change that here
to choose the right repository.
This is really important,
just because using
binary repositories can
really, really speed up
install times by, like,
several orders of magnitude.
And so it's worth it to
choose a binary repository.
That's not necessary for Python.
Python, by default,
will always give you
the binaries for your system.
So anyway.
So OK.
So now we know how I got this--
how this package
worked, that sort
of thing, why my tidyr works.
But how about, how is
this being maintained?
And so what R does
is R [INAUDIBLE]
what's called a lock file.
And so this lock file contains
my version of R, right?
It says it's R version 3.6.2.
This has that
repository in it, right?
That's that repository
that I used.
And so that-- ooh,
zoomed out too much.
This is that repository
that I had set
when I started this project.
And then I have a list
of all of my packages,
what version they are, what
repository they're using.
If I have GitHub packages,
that will record that as well.
Or, sorry, Git packages in
general-- not just GitHub,
but also GitLab, GitBucket.
And so this gets
recorded in my lock file.
And so if I want to
make another project--
let's say I want to share
this with my colleagu--
all I need to do is I need
to share the renv lock
file with them.
So here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to take
the renv lock file,
and I'm going to copy it
to the broken version.
So all that I've done--
this is the version of this
project that does not work.
Tidyr is wrong here, right?
This is-- actually, I've
got to load the data.
And tidyr does not
work here, right?
This is, again,
that wrong version
of tidyr, the new
version of tidyr.
And so now what
I'm going to do is
I'm going to do renv
init, which will
stand up my renv virtual
environment [INAUDIBLE]
this project.
And it will restore it, in
particular, from the lock file.
The other thing I just
want you to notice
is, that was almost
instantaneous in terms
of restoring that lock file.
And the reason is because renv
maintains a user-level cache.
So if I've ever installed
these packages before,
they automatically get restored.
And it is super fast.
And so now, if I go--
you'll see package
version tidyr 0.8.1.
Awesome.
Now I've got the right version.
Now I can run this code,
and it just works, right?
So this is really awesome,
and it makes an easy way
to share a project and an
environment with somebody else,
or with future you.
Great.
So one more question that
comes up all the time is,
OK, great [INAUDIBLE] but how
do I do this for a new project,
right?
How do I start this afresh?
And so it's really quite easy.
When I go to New Project
here in the RStudio IDE,
New Directory--
I'm going to start
a new project.
I'm going to call
this my_new_project.
And now all I do is I'm
going to click here,
"use renv with this project."
And now renv is going to
be set up with this project
as it starts here
on RStudio Server.
It's going to set up a new
project for me with my folder
there with my R Proj file--
that's the project folder--
and an renv library that
is attached to the project
by default, which is really
a nice thing to do here.
Now, so what this means
is that, whenever--
if I go to install packages--
if I could spell it
right, that would help--
it will install-- again, it
linked in from that cache
super, super quick.
And so that's the
part of using renv.
Now, what if I want to use
a snapshotted repository?
So there's a little
bit of judgment here
around what the
date is to choose.
You want to choose a date
that works for your project.
My general recommendation
is to choose
a date that's around the time
your product is pretty stable.
So you probably
don't want it to be
the day you start the project.
But maybe when the bulk
of the coding is done,
and you're thinking, OK, it's
time to save this for later,
you can do renv
modify and go in here.
Oh, here's my renv lock file.
And I can edit.
Let's get a repository
that's more up to date.
Let's say I want
to do yesterday.
I can get that lock file--
the right repository.
I just put it in here.
And now when I
start a new session,
it's going to automatically
set my repository
to be the right repository.
It's going to take just
a second here to reload.
But after it reloads,
what you'll see
is that it's going to be that
updated version of the package
manager repository.
Now if I want to say--
one other thing just
to be aware of is,
the way to capture dependencies
is, I'm going to save--
let's save an R file here.
And now when I do
renv snapshot, it's
going to introspect
on those files.
And it's realized that
I need ggplot2 in here
and all of its dependencies.
So this makes it
really easy to use.
You can also set
up auto snapshots
so that it will snapshot any
time you type install.packages
inside this project folder.
Great.
So that's basically
what I wanted
to share in terms of using renv.
And so we're going
to wrap up now.
And so just a couple of
things to review here.
So the thing you want
to do is-- two things
to encourage you to do.
Do a package-management
plan with your group, right?
How are you managing
repositories?
What are those settings
supposed to be?
The default repos.
And how are you
managing libraries?
And before you start your
individual data-science work,
do your mise en place.
Use renv.
And I just showed
off how to use renv
for R. The process of using
virtualenv with Python
is really, really similar.
Really similar.
If you want more
information about this,
we have website
environments.rstudio.com,
where you can feel free to check
out more information on this.
And if you're interested
in RStudio Package Manager,
if that seems like something
that your team could use,
feel free to send us an
email at sales@rstudio.com,
and we can talk
more with you there.
I'm going to pull up
the Slido questions.
OK.
"Also interested in
RStudio's docker images,
but they are advertised
as experimental."
Any idea of when they will
be out of experimental?
No.
I don't know that we
have any plans to make
them more strongly
supported than experimental
now, for the time being.
At this point, if
you want to use them,
you should feel
free to use them.
But no imminent plans
to stabilize them,
as far as I know.
Oh, this is a great question.
Somebody asks,
"Interested in the advice
that users should manage
their own libraries.
To that end, what's
your advice on the role
of a centrally-managed
site library?"
This is a great question.
I love this question.
This is a question that I
think a lot of IT folks have--
yeah, it's a really
good question.
The short answer here is that I
do not believe it's necessary.
It is definitely the case--
I strongly recommend
against trying
to disallow users from
being able to pull
their own packages, right?
Data scientists should
be able to manage
their own specific
packages for themselves.
And the reason for that
is that, for example,
let's say that I
have just a centrally
managed set of packages.
Then somebody has to do
that management, right?
Then IT has to manage
that library, which
can be very difficult in
terms of managing not only
what packages, but what
versions, what's installed,
what date was it installed?
How does that correspond
to the [INAUDIBLE]
gets really complicated
really, really fast.
And so I strongly
recommend against having
all the packages in a
centrally site-managed library.
So there is another
version of this
that-- it's a little
bit softer, which
is, an admin stands up a
starter set of packages
that are centrally installed.
And then users can install their
own packages on top of that.
But they can use the starter
set, if they want to,
so that that works [INAUDIBLE].
And there's nothing
wrong with doing that.
It's totally fine.
In most cases, it is
unnecessary, we tend to find.
The big reasons
people want to do
this are because they want to
make things easier for data
scientists to get started.
In general, folks can
install their own--
if you can library a
package, you can install it.
And if folks are having trouble
with system-level dependencies,
this is where we
recommend centralizing
those resources on
a server as opposed
to everybody working
on their own desktop.
So again, even on a
server, we recommend
everybody managing their own
individual libraries, not
a centrally managed
site library.
So that's a great question.
Here's another great question
on, "What does renv save?"
Does it include all of the
packages that are installed
or only those actually
used inside a project?
Yeah, this is a great question.
By default, if
you do a snapshot,
it snapshots only
those packages that
are in use at the current time.
And what that means is
that it can find them
somewhere in a library call
or a colon-colon call, right?
If it can find
either of those, it
will capture those
as dependencies.
This does sometimes get
people into trouble.
If people are doing
this, and then
lapply lib
install.packages, this
will not get picked
up from renv and also
is a bad process, right?
If you're doing this, this
is just a plan-- this says,
you need renv.
So if you're doing
this, don't do this.
Use renv instead.
It works way better.
It captures versions
and not just packages,
and also doesn't mess up--
this could mess up somebody's
entire package environment.
There is a way, in renv, to turn
on auto snapshotting, which is,
basically, any package that gets
installed will get snapshotted.
And so that can end up
being more than the packages
you actually need.
And then there is a
prune command, basically,
that allows you to prune
the renv library back
to only the things that
are actually being used.
Great question.
Let's see.
"Do you have a free version
of Package Manager?"
Yes, it's the public one.
RStudio Package Manager--
packagemanager.rstudio.com--
is public Package Manager.
If you want something
behind your firewall--
an internal version--
that is where our
pro product comes in.
So good question.
"Package Manager provides a way
to control the list of packages
it caches.
When will it do the same
for Python packages?"
No guarantee on when.
It is under active development
by the Package Manager team
and will be out shortly.
For those of you who aren't
quite aware, Package Manager--
the private version-- supports
Python repos, PyPI repos.
Currently, though, it only
supports full mirrors.
It does not support subsets
and that sort of thing.
This will be forthcoming
in future versions
of Package Manager.
"What is your recommendation
to use a mix"--
and this will be
the last question.
I think we're
running out of time.
"What is your
recommendation to use
a mix of
validated/public packages
in one environment in a
highly regulated environment?"
Yeah, this is a great question.
So there are a bunch of
different ways to do this.
The most common way
we see this done is--
I'm going to go back to-- this
is our internal demo version
of Package Manager--
is, you can create a
validated repository here
inside RStudio Package Manager.
And that can sit aside, right?
You can have multiple repos.
And so you can do this yourself.
I'm showing you in
RStudio Package Manager,
but you can do this
in other tools.
This is not an RStudio Package
Manager [INAUDIBLE] thing,
but I happen to have an
example here in RStudio Package
Manager.
You can create a
validated repository
that has only those validated
packages in it, right?
And you can specify the
versions and the packages.
And you can have
that sitting beside.
This is a full
CRAN mirror, right?
And so what you can do,
then, is you can say, OK,
for the validated projects,
use the validated repository,
right?
And you, again, just go
to the Setup tab here.
Make sure you're using the
appropriate binary repository.
And if you want to, choose
a date, if you want to.
And if you're doing a
more public project that
doesn't need that high
degree of validation,
just use the all-in
public repository.
Or, the alternative
is, you could
have the validated for
the validated repository
and the public--
you could just literally
use a public CRAN mirror.
This isn't quite as
ideal, because then, it's
a little easier to mess up.
But that's the
recommendation there.
I know we did not have time to
get to all the questions here.
Unfortunately, we're,
I think, out of time.
I will be putting together some
more materials on this topic
and emailing them
out, so I really
appreciate all the questions.
I will take a look at
all these questions.
And we'll probably
include a little FAQ
in some of the future
documents we send out.
And we'll try and address as
many of these as possible.
Again, I really, really
appreciate everybody's time
today and for sticking
with us through all
the technical
difficulties today.
I've never quite had a
webinar go like this.
But I really appreciate
everybody sticking with us
and hope you got something
out of the time today.
So thanks so much for
joining, and look forward
to hearing from you more soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]